الثمن والعشرين من مايو ولاول مره في
تاريخ تركيا الحديث
الاتراكز ينتخبون رئيسهم عبر دور ثان جوله
ثانيه وذلك بعد ان فشل كل من رجب طيب
اردوغان وكمال اوغلو في حصد نصف اصوات
الناخبين لتتحول الانظار الى الخاسر في
الجوله الاولى الحصان الاسود السنان اوغان
الذي يمثل خمسه في المئه من الاصوات لديه
وما يكفي لقلبي تاخرك لجدار الى فوز او
حسم النتيجه لصالح اردوغان لكن دعونا اولا
نذكر بما حدث في الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات حصل اردوغان على نسبه
49.52% نال الاغلبيه في 51 ولايه من اصل
81 وفاز في 8 من اصل احدى عشره ولايه
ضربها الزلزال وهي كهرمان مرعش غازي عنتاب
كلس اديمان عثمانيه
بالطبع خسر اردوغان في ديار بكر معقل
الاكراد الى جانب اضنه وهاتاي منافسه كمال
اكل جدار اوغلو حصل على نسبه اجماليه بلغت
44.8 من الاسواق هذا اصوات الاغلبيه في 30
ولايه اخرى وابرزها كانت العاصمه انقره
واسطنبول والمفارقه في اتجاهات التصويت في
هاتين المنطقتين انها على الرغم من عدم
تصويتها لاردوغان في انتخابات الرئاسه
صوتت لصالح تحالفه في البرلمان
[موسيقى]
الله
باجماع السلطه والمعارضه شهدت تركيا اطول
اسبوعين في تاريخها ارتفعت خلالهما حراره
الانتخابات اردوغان الذي لم ينهزم في اخر
عشر انتخابات خاضها لجا الى سنان اوغان
الذي مثل كسب اصواته ما يشبه المزاد لكن
مشكله اوجان هي انه يقود تحالفا ولا يمتلك
حبا اصواته قد تتفكك وهو الذي تدعمه اربعه
احزاب يمينيه تشترك في خطوط البرنامج
العريض لكنها قد لا توافق سنان في ميوله
لاردغان الذي لا يلبي رغبات اقصى اليمين
اعلنوا اننا ندعم المترشح رجب طيب اردوغان
في الدور الثاني من الانتخابات ادعو
الناخبين الذين صوتوا لنا في الدور الاول
لدعم المترشح اردوغان في الدور الثاني
حده المنافسه تزداد في الانتخابات التركيه
قبل ساعات من معرفه الرئيس الجديد وسنان
اوغان سيكون لاعبا مؤثرا في نتيجه
الانتخابات ينتمي للتيار القومي وحد اغلب
احزاب اليمين في برنامج واحد تمكن من
خلاله حصد مليونين وثمانمائه الف صوت هذه
النسبه كان من المفترض ان تصوت المحرم
انجي غير انه انسحب من السباق بعد حصول
سنان على الاصوات كانت اول واهم شروطه
لدعم احد المرشحين هي اعاده ملايين
اللاجئين الى بلادهم السوريين تحديدا نقطه
تلتقي مع برنامج كريستار اوغلو والحزب
الحاكم هو الاخر لا يمانع الخطوه شرط
اوغان الثاني هو قطع العلاقه مع كل
الاحزاب التي تربطها علاقه مباشره مع
الاكراد وهذا شرط تعجيزي لكلا المترشحين
اردوغان يتمتع بدعم حزب الدعوه مره الكردي
المعارض لحزب العمال الكردستاني وهو ما
يمثل واحدا في المئه تقريبا من اصوات
الناخبين كتله هامه ووفيه لن يتنازل عنها
اردوغان والامر الاكثر تعقيدا بالنسبه لك
الذي يحظى بدعم حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي
المقرب من الاكراد حزب حصل على 8% من
الاصوات في انتخابات 2014
ولا سبيل لاقصائه
[موسيقى]
بدون اي تنازلات اثارها حفيظه احزاب
تحالفه الاربعه
زعيم وحزب النصر احد اكبر احزاب التحالف
اكد ان قرار اوجان لا يمثل الا شخصه وقال
لم يعد يتحدث باسمي 5% من الاصوات
استطلاعات الراي اكدت ان جزءا كبيرا منهم
لن يذهب للانتخابات حزب النصر بزعامه
اوزداج يمثل نصف الاصوات 2.5% اعلن دعمه
الذي يلبي مطالبه بخصوص ملف الهجره حزبه
العداله اليمني كان اول من اختار حليفه
اختار طريقا معاكسا لاوجان وهذه المره قرر
دعمك لجدار اوغلو الحزب يمثل
السفر.2% من الاصوات غالبيه اصوات اوغان
قد تتبع توجيهات زعماء الاحزاب وتذهب
للمعارضه لكن اردوغان في النهايه لا ينقصه
الكثير للفوز حتى وان مثل اوجان واحد
فاصله خمسه في المئه من الاصوات
لكن المفارقه انه وبعد اعلان اوزداك دعمه
تداول البعض على مواقع التواصل هذا المقطع
اذا فازت لجدار اوغلو ستحدث حرب من القائل
بنفسه
اذا فاز كلجدار اوغلو في الانتخابات سيكون
الفضل لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطي ونظرا لانهم
يدعمون في انتخابات الرئاسه سيعملون لصالح
الارهاب باريحيه بدون اي رادع او مانع منه
في النهايه تحدث فوضى في جنوب شرق
الاناضول وتتجه بلديات حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي لطلب المعونه من عده دول وعقب
وصول المعونه الدوليه ستدخل تركيا في اتون
حرب داخليه
لجزء من اصوات اقصى اليمين لم يخلوا من
التنازلات ففي مقطع المصور نشره على صفحته
حذر الاتراك من وصول عشاره ملايين اجنبي
حاله فوز اردوغان رغم ان العدد الرسمي حتى
منتصف مايو كان نحو ثلاثه ملايين
اردوغان غير قادر على حمايه الحدود غدا
سيصل 10 ملايين لاجئ وربما 30 مليونا انهم
يشكلون تهديدا لوطننا ان لم نتحرك
لم يذكر مصدر تقديراته لكنه كسب تاييد
المراه التركيه
المهاجرون القادمون الى بلادنا يحملون
نظره سلبيه عن المراه التركيه هي نظره
خاليه من الاحترام
مصدر اخر [__] كنزا من الاصوات من اختار
عدم المشاركه في الجوله الاولى
12% من اصل اربعه وستين مليون ناخذ تقريبا
اقل من عشره ملايين من الصعب معرفه
توجهاتهم لكن الطرفين حاول اقناع جزء منهم
يختلف الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان ومنافسه
كمال كلجدار اوغلو في كل القضايا تقريبا
فيردوان يريد الابقاء على النظام الرئاسي
مع تعديلات لتجاوز بعض نقاط الضعف بينما
يريد منافسه العوده الى النظام البرلماني
والغاء النظام الرئاسي فيما يخص الاقتصاد
يؤكد انه سيواصل سياسته الراميه لخفض معدل
التضخم وخفض سعر الفائده فيما يعد
باعطاء استقلاليه كامله للبنك المركزي على
صعيد السياسه الخارجيه يرغب اردوغان في
مواصله نهجه المتمثل بالتقارب مع موسكو
دون التخلي عن الغرب والولايات المتحده مع
بقاء نفس السياسه فيما يخص سحب القوات
التركيه من سوريا لكن هذا النهجه يعارضه
زعيم المعارضه الذي يقول انه سيتقارب مع
الغرب اكثر على حساب العلاقات مع روسيا
عدا عن انه يريد تطبيع العلاقات مع دمشق
واعاده اللاجئين في اسرع وقت وسحب الجيش
من شمال سوريا
من باريس ينضم الينا الدكتور جان بيرمي
للمحلل السياسي والاستاذ المتخصص في شؤون
الشرق الاوسط في المدرسه العليا في باريس
اهلا بك الخصمان وصل الى المعركه الاخيره
في هذه الانتخابات المحتدمه والمفصليه في
تركيا ما اخر الاسلحه التي لديك
استخدامها هل لا زالت ورقه اللاجئين وازنه
بين يديه ويتحدث عن اعاده 10 ملايين لاجئ
الى بلادهم في حال فوزه
مساء الخير لاحظنا في تقديمكم المفصل ان
حدوث
ما زالت ضئيله امام فوز محتمل
لاردوان
الجدير بذكر اذا تاكد انه يدخل في عهد
الثالث ان السياسه الداخليه والخارجيه
مرتبطان يعني الخطاب الشوفيني
الداخلي مرتبات
بتغيير جذري في النظره
الخارجيه اذكر ان وزير الداخليه ليردوان
صرح قبل بضعه اصابيع
متكلما
للولايات المتحده لا تمس تركيا بايديكم
الوسخه هذا الاسلوب
المتطرف هذه
الشحنه الكلاميه مرتبطه بالداخل لان هناك
نزعه وطنيه قويه في في تركيا
وهي مرتبطه كذلك
بنوازع استقلاليه
لتركيا في السياسه الخارجيه نعم ولكن بما
يتعلق بحدود كليجدار اوغلو كنت اسالك على
موضوع اللاجئين الذي تحدث عنه وهو تحدث
ايضا هناك نقطه مهمه تحدث عن عشره ملايين
لاجئ بينما يعني ليس رد اردوغان الذي تحدث
ان الرقم ليس صحيحا ولكن ايضا منظمه
الهجره تقول ان عدد اللاجئين وثلاثه فاصله
سته مليون سوري وهناك 400 الف من جنسيات
عربيه اخرى يعني الرقم بعيد ايضا الا يعد
هذا تزييفا تغيير للوقائع لكسب اصوات
مؤيده له في هذه
المرحله الحاسمه
لا لا شك ان هناك مزايده في في الارقام
ولكن مثل ما قلته هي هو خطاب شوفيني لكاسب
اصوات النخبين الذين
تبنىوا هذه الافكار الجدير بالذكر في
برنامج
انه مثلا تكلم عن سحب الجيش من شمال سوريا
تكلم عن الابتعاد عن النفوذ الروسي كما
تطرق
عن مشاكل اقتصاديه مثلا استقلاليه البنك
المركزي نعرف ان ارقام التضخم
المالي في
في تركيا هائله لذلك
قلت فيما سبق ان الداخل والخارج
مرتبطان يعني سياسه اردوغان في السنوات
الاخيره لم
سياسه توازن بل ارجوحه يعني
سناتي على هذه النقطه دكتور سناتي على هذه
النقطه ولكن سنتوقف عند نقطه اخرى يعني
المنافسه بين اردوغان وكلي جدار اوغلو
وصلت للقضاء محامي الاخير جلال جليك غرد
على موقع تويتر واوضح انه تم رفع دعوه
قضائيه ضد اردوغان ومطالبته بمليون ليره
تركيه تقريبا 47 الف يورو والسبب هو فيديو
زائف نشره اردوغان يربط كليجدار اوغلو
بمقاتلي حزب العمال الكردستانيه الذي
تصنفه انقره ارهابيه
[موسيقى]
نعود الى ضيفنا من باريس الدكتور جانبير
ميل دكتور يعني الفوز بالنسبه لاردوغانا
بهذه الظروف وبهذه الصعوبه حتى يعني اضطر
اظهار فيديو مفبرك وقال لاحقا انه فيديو
مركب يعني الفوز بالنسبه لاردوغان هل
يعتبر انتصارا بعد كل هذا
طبعا
سلوكات اردوغان معروفه هو الرجل السلطاوي
وتحكمي
لا يتردد في ان يلجا الى الصليب غير
مقبوله مثلا في البلدان
الديموقاتيه الكبرى
لعجب ان يتطرق بهذه الطريقه الى نقط
منافسه ولكن فيما
فيما قلته فيما سبق لاننا قلنا اننا نعود
الى السياسه الخارجيه
قلته ان اردوغان له اسلوب خاص في السنوات
الاخيره
وهذا الاسلوب يدل على فجوه بين
اوروبا والولايات المتحده من جهه وبين
تركيا من جهه اخرى لذلك ذكرت تصريح وزير
الداخليه مثلا تركيا تدين الغزو روسيا على
اوكرانيا
وتستفيد من الاموال الروسيه ان كانت اموال
الاوليجارد او اموال الحكومه وحتى
الهاربين من من التجنيد
فهذه
التناقضات هي اسلوب اوردوان مع بعض
الممارسات يعني
اسالك عنه اكثر بخصوص بخصوص كلجدار اوغلو
ولكن سنتوقف قليلا عند هذه النقطه واعود
اليك دكتور حليف اخر خي باظنك للجدار
اوغلو الدول الغربيه
بقيه المترشحين لرئاسه الدول لم يتلقى اي
دعوه للزياره او رساله دعم علانيه رغم انه
اختار صفه بعيدا عن روسيا ومعسكرها ورغم
توتر علاقات اردوغان مع اوروبا على خلفيه
ازمته مع اليونان ومع النيتو ومعارضته في
وقت ما انضمام السويد ومن قبلها فنلندا
جعلت الغرب لا يخفي رغبته في رؤيه رئيس
تركيا جديد الا ان الدول الغربيه رفضت
تقديم دعما واضح لكلاش دار اولو هي مخاطر
رهان خاسر او ربما بسبب ذهاب المترشح
المعارض بعيدا حين اعطى وعودا انتخابيه
اوروبيه دون موافقه بروكسيل دخوله اوروبا
دون تاشيره اضافه لكسر اتفاقيه اللجوء
التي تجمع انقره ببروكسل اوروبا لا ترغب
في رؤيه ملايين المهاجرين على الحدود مره
اخرى بالطبع اذا اعود الى ضيفنا من فريسه
الدكتور جانبير دكتور
هذا الموقف
الاوروبي الغربي الامريكي يعني نحن نعلم
ان ان امريكا واوروبا تتمنى رئيسا تركيا
جديدا ولكن لماذا لم تظهر هذا الدعم لك
اظن ان خشيه الخوف من
تهمه التدخل في الانتخابات
عندما
قالو
انه يرفض التدخلات الروسيه في الانتخابات
كانت الرساله واضحه من قبل الدول الغربيه
هناك حضار راينا ذكرتم رفض تركي للانضمام
الى السويد الى الى الناتو مع ان تركيا هو
عادو كبير في الناتو
فهناك احيانا
تقلبات
مفاجئه في الموقف التركي ولكن بشكل عام ما
هو مهم لسنوات المقبله
هو ان
الاستراتيجيه الاوروبيه والامريكيه من جهه
والاستراتيجيه التركيه لا يلتقيان كما
كانت الحال اما في القرن العشرين ايام
الديكتاتوريه العسكريه حيث كانت تركيا
تابعه للولايات المتحده مباشره ثم في
ثمانينات وتسعينيات القرن الماضي كان هناك
عباره عن توازن وانفتاح من قبل تركيا
مع الرئيس اردوغان هناك عباره عن انفراد
عن الركود الى الامام لتركيا مع ان
التصرف التحكمي لارضوان سببا مشاكل
اقتصاديه هائله وها هو شكر بعض ما سمى دول
الخليج ولكننا نعرف انها قطر والامارات
العربيه المتحده اولا التي حولت او
استبعدت شكرا لك دكتورنا من الوقت اشكرك
جزيل الشكر معنا من باريس دكتوره اجانب
المحلل السياسي والاستاذ المتخصص في شؤون
الشرق الاوسط في المدرسه العليا في باريس
كوابيس وازمات نفسيه تبعات والنزاعيه في
السودان ساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد استمراره الحرب في
اوكرانيا يرجع الى اصرار جميع الاطراف على
حل النزاع بالوسائل العسكريه ومع كل تصعيد
تزداد مخاوف وقوع صدام مباشر بين روسيا
والنيتو والذي قد ينتهي بضربه النوويه
واخرى مضاده كل من موسكو وواشنطن عاملات
طيله الحرب البارده على الاستعداد لهذه
اللحظه ورغم عقودا من الابحاث وعشرات
المليارات بقي اعتراض الصواريخ البالستين
النوويه مهمه مستحيله وهنا تركزت الابحاث
على ما يسمى بنظام الانذار المبكر
[موسيقى]
لنتصور مثلا انا صاروخا باليستيا منطلق من
موسكو نحو واشنطن او العكس الصاروخ سيبلغ
هدفه في اقل من 30 دقيقه والمسار سيكون في
اغلبه في الفضاء ولا توجد حتى الان انظمه
قادره على اعتراضه على هذا الارتفاع وهنا
تبرز اهميه نظام الانذار المبكر مجموعه من
الرادارات الضخمه اي نشاط ارصد اي نشاط
صاروخي مباشره بعد الاطلاق والولايات
المتحده طورت منذ انتهاء الحرب البارده
نظاما يرتبط بالاقمار الصناعيه وشبكه
رادرات نصبت في اراضي حلفاء روسيا
السابقين في الوقت نفسه خسرت موسكو عده
رادارات للانذار المبكر بسبب تفكك اراضيها
وهي كانت في ليتوانيا اوكرانيا وبيلاروسيا
وهنا جاءت الحاجه لبناء نظام حديث المشروع
لقب ببوروج واعادت روسيا من خلاله ثمانيه
رادارات من سانت بترسبرج شمالا الى البحر
الاسود جنوبا
[موسيقى]
الجدار الحمايه الاول تحول الى قضيه
يشربها الفساد المشكله لا تتعلق فقط
بخساره ملايين الدولارات بل الاهم هو نظام
حمايه غير فعال في زمن الحرب
موقعنا روسي متخصص في كشف قضايا الفساد
يسمى المجرمون الروس كشف ان جهاز الامن
الفيدرالي بصدد التحقيق في قضيه تتعلق
برادار بارونج للانذار المبكر والعيب ليس
في التصميم ولا في قدرات الرادار على
الورق بل في الشركه التي انجزت المشروع
استوردت مكونات لا تصلح للاستخدام العسكري
لما تكلف الا سنتات قليله بدلا من وضع
المكونات المطلوبه التي تكلف مئات
الدولارات واتهم وجهه هنا لشركتين اي اف
كي
اي جي اس سي وهناك اخفاق اخر ايضا تحديث
الرادارات لم يشمل النظام الطنط التنسيق
والانذار وهو ما يشبه مشاهده افلام فائقه
الدفاع عبر شاشات قديمه
هذا الفساد ليس هو فقط ما يعوق مجهود
روسيا الحربي صمود علمائها الكبار امام
الاغراءات الغربيه ايضا ظاهره تعود للحرب
البارده لكنها امتدت لتشمل علماء اهم
برنامج عسكري تكنولوجيا الصواريخ فرط
الصوتيه ومن مهد كنجال معهد سيبيريا
للميكانيك النظريه والتطبيقيه الامن
الروسيه اعتقل العالمان الكسندر شيبليون
مازالوب الصيف الماضي بتهمه تسريب اسرار
عسكريه للخارج اداره المعهد عجبت من
القرار بحجه ان العالمين لم يشاركا الا في
نشر ابحاث في مجلات علميه بموافقه السلطات
الامنيه الا ان الرد جاء الاسبوع الماضي
باعتقال عالم ثالث من المعهد بيليريا
مختص في ديناميك الهواء متهم بتسريب
معلومات سريه للصين اداره المعهد اكدت انه
غير قادر على العمل بدون ابرز علمائه حذر
من هجره ادمغه
[موسيقى]
تخيل ان الاقتصاد الامريكي اقد انهار
واننا امام ازمه اقتصاديه عالميه ليست فقط
شبيهه بما حدث عام 2008 ستبدو الازمه
الماليه العالميه هذه مره وكانها حفله شاي
وذلك بتوصيف كبير الاقتصاديين في بنك
الاستثمار فان مورغدن هذا الخيال يمكن ان
يصبح واقعا مع تخلف الولايات المتحده عن
سداد ديونها بحلول اول من يونيو وقد تفلس
الحكومه في الخامس من يونيو نعم نقصد هذين
التاريخين القادمين بعد ايام
المقر عام 1917 حريه الاقتراض لكن بشرط
الالتزام بصف محدد قانون الفائده شرع
ليتغير حصل هذا مئه مره منذ اعتماده
الكونجرس يتدخل في كل مره برفع السقف لكن
الاجراء الروتوني يتحول احيانا الى ساحه
لتصفيه حسابات سياسيه على حساب الاقتصاد
كما حدث وقت اوباما
تبدو الازمه الحاليه مشابهه لازمه العام
2011 بين اداره اوباما والجمهوريه ولكن
المره الماضيه كان هناك اطراف اكثر
متدخلين في هذه الازمه ومن بينهم اعضاء
مجلس الشيوخ بالاضافه الى اعضاء مجلس
النواب من الجمهوريين وتسببت الازمه حين
ذاك بانهيار الثقه بسندات الخزينه
الامريكيه وبرفع اسعار الفائده
هذه المره تاخذ وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
اجراءات سريعه لضمان الثقه واستمرارها
ويبدو انها سوف تدفع اولا المستحقات على
سندات الخزينه وسوف تسير الاسواق كالمعتاد
ايضا المصارف الخاصه سوف تعفي المواطنين
من ايه عقوبات لو لم تصل اليهم معاشاتهم
الحرب العالميه الاولى جعلت القانون
الامريكي موجودا والان حرب اخرى في
اوكرانيا تستنزف ميزانيه واشنطن وجعلت جمع
الضرائب اقل من المتوقع لتكون واشنطن امام
حلين احلاهما مروا الاول التخلف عن السداد
وهنا كارثه معنى ذلك ان واشنطن لم تعد
قادره على رفع فوائد ديونها ستضطر للدخول
في مفاوضات مع الدائنين الذين بدورهم
سيضطرون للجدوله ديونهم او شتوي جزء منها
ارتفاع الديون يعني ان هناك الكثير ممن هم
مستعدون لاقراض واشنطن لماذا لان الديون
الامريكيه تعتبر استثمارا مضمونا بمخاطر
شبه معدومه لكن عجز امريكا عن السداد
سيجعل الثقه في سنداتها تهتز والفائده تر
تفع ما يجعل المستثمرين يفرون من اسواق
امريكا بسبب غلاء القرود وتداعيات ستصل
لنا جميعا
[موسيقى]
الادارات الامريكيه لطالما نجحت في رفع
سقف الدين بالرغم من الجدل السياسي
المرافق لكن لنفرض ان هذا لن يحدث او على
الاقل سيتاخر هل يمتلك الرئيس بايدن
صلاحيات تنقذ الموقف رفع سقف الفائده كان
ليكون مجرد اجراء بسيط لولا نتائج
انتخابات التجديد النصفيه التي جاءت
بالجمهوريين على راس مجلس النواب وفي هذه
الحاله الى قرار دون اقناعهم الجمهوريون
وضعوا شروطهم التي ستحد مما وصفوه باسراف
اداره بايدن في الانفاق وشبهوا سياسته
بالطفل الذي انفق امواله قبل الموعد وهو
الان يطلب المزيد
ادارته بعيدا وصفت مطالب الجمهوريين
بتخفيض الميزانيه ب 4,500 مليار دولار
بمطلب تعجيزي يدمر العائلات الامريكيه
الجمهوريون عللوا ما يفعله كذا مكارثي
رئيس مجلس النواب بان البلاد عاجزه عن دفع
فوائد القرود التي تم انفاقها فعليا
والامر لا يتعلق بطلب قروض جديده لانفاقها
شبحوا التخلف عن السداد الذي يخيم على
الاقتصاد الامريكي جعل قيمه التامين على
سندات الخزانه الامريكيه تفوق ديون دوله
مثل اليونان وخوفا من الصدمه جهزت الخزانه
الامريكيه اجراءات بديله البدايه من تعليق
قانون سقف الدين مؤقتا مما يسمح بالصرف
معاشات التقاعد والمعلمين حصل هذا سابقا
سبع مرات حل ثانى اقترحه ترامب سابقا لحل
ازمه الدين وهو طبع النقود بالتاكيد سيحل
ازمه السيوله لكنه سيرفع معدلات التضخم
التي تكافح اداره بايدن لكبحها ولكبح جماح
التضخم
ستضطر واشنطن لرفع الفائده لتبلغ معدلات
مغريه بما فيه الكفايه من اجل جذب اموال
المودعين الى البنوك وهو اجراء ليسمح
بكبحي الطلب على السلع لكن معدلات الفائده
المرتفعه بدورها ستقتل الاستثمارات وقطاع
العقارات وهنا ازمه اخرى دائره
مغلقه قد تجبر بايدن على استغلال صلاحياته
الدستوريه
[موسيقى]
الاطفال هم الفئه الاضعف في الصراعات وهذا
ينطبق بالطبع على نزاع في السودان ترى نحو
اثنين وثمانين الف طفلا الى الدول
المجاوره واصبح
368 الف اخرين نازحين داخليا منذ بدء
النزاع الاطفال الذين لا يزالون في
السودان يعيشون محنه
رهيبه بحسب مديره يونس في السودان اطفال
السودان يعانون اضطراب ما بعد الصدمه ونقل
بعده بعضهم للمستشفيات النفسيه داخل
السودان فيما دشنت مصر مثلا وحدات دعم
نفسيا للاطفال تضم عيادات متنقله وثابته
على المعابر الحدوديه بهدف تقديم الدعم
النفسي للاطفال والمراهقين والعلاج المبكر
لما يسمى بامراض النزوح
فجاه فجاه من غير اي مقدمات بس سمينا
اصوات
[موسيقى]
كده قاعدين خايفين
تقيم في اي لحظه ممكن نفقد واحد مننا
نفسيا جسديا في منا عيانين المرضى وما
عندنا علاج في اكيل البيض الاكل البيضه
ينقص في البيت
خطرا كبير على الانتخابات في الاعوام
القادمه في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كلما تقدمت تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي استفاد الانسان لكن القلق يظل
حاضرا ايضا الامر يشكل خطرا وجوديا على
حياتنا
بحسبث المدير التنفيذي السابق لشركه جوجل
وهذا القلق يتنامى منذ ظهور تشات ودلئي
والتساؤل المخيف هو هل يستولي الذكاء
الاصطناعي على وظائفنا نعم بعض الوظائف
ستكون في خطر فمن سيكون ضحيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي الوظائف التقنيه هي الاكثر عرضه
للخطر مثل البرمجه وتحليل البيانات ستنتج
الاكواد باسرع مما يمكن انتاجه من طرف
البشر وبتكلفه اقل حتى ان شركه اوبن اي اي
مصممه تشاد جي بي تي بدات بتدريب تقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي على برمجه الحواسيب
وظائف الاعلام هي الاخرى معرضه لخطر
الانقراض الاعلانات والصحافه مثلا ما
السبب قدرته الذكاء الاصطناعي على قراءه
البيانات النصيه وكتابتها وفهمها والقائها
وهنا المهدد انا على الجانب الاخر ستبقى
بعض الوظائف خاصه بالانسان فقط المحامون
والقضاه مثلا فالذكاء الاصطناعي لا يمكنه
قراءه المشاعر رغم انها تشاد جي بي تي
اربعه تحديدا نبات يتقدم في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
اخر حول الذكاء الاصطناعي الانتخابات قد
تكون في خطر وبسبب المعلومات المضلله
والمحتوى المزيف الذي قد يتم انشاؤه مع
امكانيه استخدام الذكاء الاصطناعي كوقودا
عاطفي يؤثر على توجهات الناخبين قد يكون
ذلك خطابا او بيانا صحفيا او صوره او نكته
او فيديو يروج لفوائد مرشح على حساب اخر
مثال بسيط قبل شهر استخدمت اللجنه الوطنيه
التابعه للحزب الجمهوري الامريكي تقنيه
لتصميم فيديو لتدعيه مرعبه في حال اعاده
انتخاب بايدن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الامر ليس خاصا فقط بالانتخابات الامريكيه
فحوالي مليار ناخبئس يتوجهون العام المقبل
الى صناديق الاقتراع في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده الهند والاتحاد الاوروبي
واندونيسيا وروسيا وبريطانيا
لم يخفي رئيس الوزراء ريشسوناك طموحه بان
يجعل المملكه المتحده قوه عظمى في مجال
الذكاء الاصطناعي ولكن رغم تعالي الاصوات
لتقنين هذه التكنولوجيا التي تشهد تطورا
سريعا اكتفت الحكومه البريطانيه بانها
ستقود الحد من مخاطر الذكاء الاصطناعي
معتمده على اللوائح الحاليه بدلا من ادخال
ما تسميه بالتشريعات القاسيه الخانقه
للابتكار خبراء حذروا من ان الانتخابات
المقبله يمكن ان تتميز بموجه من المعلومات
الخاطئه المدعومه بالذكاء الاصطناعي ما لم
تتعامل الحكومه بسرعه مع هذه التكنولوجيا
التي قد تهدد البشريه فريق عمل يعنى
بنماذج الذكاء الاصطناعي الاساسيه سيرسي
دائما الاستخدام الامن للنماذج الذكيه في
مختلف قطاعات الاقتصاد التي قد ترفع
الناتج المحليه باكثر من عشره في المئه
بحلول 2030
في السياره الذاتيه القياده في اكتشاف احد
المشاه او مركبه اخرى فقد يؤدي ذلك الى
حدوث تصادم مخاوف الخصوصيه سلبيه اخرى
بمعنى ان يتم قرصنه اجهزه الاستشعار
والكاميرات وبالتالي الوصول الى كميات
هائله من البيانات حول تحركات الركاب
وسلوكهم
[موسيقى]
من القاهره ينضم الينا المهندس احمد اباضه
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه سينابس اناليتكس
لحلول الذكاء الاصطناعي اهلا بك يعني هناك
حاله من التوجس والخوف الكبيرين
تعتري فئات معينه بسبب التطور الذكاء
الاصطناعي والرقمنه يعني
دعنا نتحدث عن معايير
التعويض تعويض الانسان بالاله ما هي
المعايير ومن الذي يجب ان يخاف اكثر من
الاخر
اهلا بك يا فندم هو طبعا زي اي تكنولوجيا
وزي اي تغيير دايما مخيف وليه ايجابيات
وليه سلبيات الفكره كلها ان ذكاء
الاصطناعي يمكن تكنولوجيا
قد تكون باهميه الانترنت او باهميه
اختراع الطباعه او كده فده بيؤدي الى ان
لازم العالم والحكومات والسياسات
والصناعات كلها تتغير انها تعرف تشتغل
وتتعامل مع هديه وتكنولوجيا الجديده
تكنولوجيا دي زي ما ليها سلبيات زي ما لها
ايجابيات قويه جدا السلبيات منها طبعا
اكيد في وظائف هتختفي اكيد في وظائف
هتتغير هيحتاج
ناس كتير قوي
للاسف بالضبط يعني لو تحدد لنا الوظائف
التي ستتاثر ذكرنا بعضها ولكن لو تساعدنا
في المزيد في المزيد من الشرح
يمكن يا فندم الوظائف اللي هتتغير ملهاش
سقف يعني احنا داخلين على تكنولوجيا جديده
جدا
ويمكن كل الوظائف تقريبا في خطر يعني
حضرتك قلتي في المقدمه هنا مثلا حاجه زي
القضاء القضاء الذكاء الاصطناعي قادر انه
يحكم في قضايا كتير
ويقدر ياخد قرارات كتيره جدا هل احنا
هنسمح له بكده ولا لا هل نقدر نعلم الذكاء
الاصطناعي العواطف او التسامح او كده ولا
لا كل دي اسئله موجوده بس الوظائف كلها
تحت خطر انها
الذكاء الاصطناعي يقدر يعملها ومش بس كده
يعني هو ذكاء مش عايزين يبدلها وممكن كمان
يزيد من انتاجيه
اي وظيفه من الوظائف دي كانت امكانات
البرمجه او صانع المحتوى او الصحافه او
القضاء
يعني الوظائف التي نقوم بها وظائف تكميليه
يعني وظائف الذكاء الاصطناعي
صحيح تكميليه واذكاء الاصطناعي كل ما
بيكبر كل ما هيخلق وظائف تانيه يعني عارفه
حضرتك مثلا زي مكاتب المراجعه
للشركات اللي بتراجع القوائم الماليه
للشركات وهكذا حضرتك بعد شويه هنلاقي
شركات قائمه على مراجعه الذكاء الاصطناعي
وتفسير ذكاء الاصطناعي وتفسير التكنولوجيا
دي ومراجعه الشركات ومسؤوليه ومسائله
الشركات دي في استخدامها لذكاء الاصطناعي
وهكذا فهو دايما التغيير بيجي بسلبيات
وايجابيات فاحنا طبعا
التركيز الانظار تتجه الى السنوات على
الخمسه المقبله استاذ احمد يعني نتمنى ان
لا يكون الاثر سلبيا جدا على الوظائف
اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت معنا من القاهره
المهندس احمد اباظه الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
سينابس انالتكس لحلول ذكاء الاصطناعي لذلك
مشاهدينا نكون قد وصلنا الى ختام الساعه
ولكن نختمها معكم من اسبانيا حكومتها بصدد
اصدار تطبيق جديد لمراقبه لمشاركه الرجال
بالاعمال المنزليه من الان وحتى الساعه
المقبله انا حنين الشولي وهذه الساعه ستون
[موسيقى]